OK, I'll give it to you straight --
we need at least four trillion
dollars per year by 2030
to avert a climate crisis.
And right now, that money
simply isn't flowing
at the rate we need
to keep this planet habitable.
Now I work with a lot
of banks and investors,
and everyone who I talk to --
and I work with some
of the leading ones around the world --
they get what needs to be done.
They're aware of the climate risks
and they're actually really excited
about the unprecedented opportunities
to finance the green economy
of the future.
And here's the good news.
Over 450 financial institutions
around the world
have committed to aligning
their financing to net-zero
by 2050.
And collectively,
these financial institutions
manage over 130 trillion dollars.
OK, so we need trillions,
we've got trillions.
Problem solved, right?
Shortest TED Talk ever.
(Laughter)
I wish that were the case.
But now, as we're working
to deliver on those commitments,
it's actually proving to be really hard.
Like, really hard to deploy real money
into real technologies
that will actually
really decarbonize the world.
And as a result, too much of that money,
it's sitting on the sidelines,
waiting to be put to work.
But I think we can change that.
And it's not even what I think --
I know we can,
because it's based on what banks
and investors tell me
about what they need
to go fast and go far.
And what they need is help
from people like you and me.
So to bring this idea to life,
let's zoom in on one part of the economy,
one that we can all relate to --
it's close to home.
Let's talk about housing.
Because, believe it or not,
the challenges we're facing with housing
and the challenges
we're facing with climate
are inextricably linked,
so as we solve for one,
we can solve for the other.
You see, we're facing two concurrent
challenges right now, with housing.
On one hand, there's
an affordability challenge.
There's just a scarcity of homes
that are affordable right now.
Here in the United States,
there's a scarcity
of over seven million homes
that people who live at or below
the poverty line can afford to rent.
And the other affordability challenge
is it's less affordable
than ever before to live in one,
because they're so energy-inefficient.
These older, less energy-efficient homes
tend to be in Black
and Brown neighborhoods
due to the structural nature of poverty.
And get this --
a recent study found
that the average renter who is Black
pays over 250 dollars more
per year in utility bills
than one who is white.
OK, so we need to build
a lot more affordable housing.
Great.
But that's when we run
into the climate challenge,
because the buildings that we live in
are one of the leading contributors
to the greenhouse gasses
that are fueling climate change.
And if we take
a business-as-usual approach
to just building all this housing,
we'll only exacerbate
the climate challenge.
Think about the emissions
from all that cement
and steel and concrete
that goes into a high-rise, for example.
So, a pretty sticky challenge.
But that's why I love working
in sustainable finance and investing,
because we get to take
challenges like this
and transform them to opportunities,
specifically financing opportunities.
Opportunities to deploy debt, equity,
grants by governments,
investors and banks.
And in the housing sector,
the financing opportunities are enormous.
We recently did a study.
We found over a trillion dollars' worth
of things that banks can finance
to lower the emissions
associated with our housing.
OK, great, so what will it take?
How can we actually get this done?
Well, here's the catch.
You see, banks work
within prescribed risk thresholds,
and some of the things we need most --
like replacements for that high-carbon
cement, steel, concrete --
they're being developed
by companies right now
that are still relatively early-stage,
and might not yet fit
within those risk thresholds.
Similarly, building affordable homes
in a low-income community
or a low-income country
might not reach the return thresholds
that investors are looking for.
When I talk to banks and investors,
they say they need
the right type of public policies,
they need the right type of capital
and they need demand
in order to put this money to work.
So that's where you and I can come in,
because there are some simple moves
that you and I can do
that can help to create the conditions
that will allow this money to flow.
I'm going to talk you
through these different moves,
and as I'm talking, just bear in mind,
these moves are not exclusive to housing.
We could apply this playbook in any sector
where we need faster climate action.
OK, let's dive in.
The first thing that we can do
to really move these trillions of dollars
is make the climate-housing connection
matter to government.
Governments have a huge role to play
in climate finance.
But when I talk to banks and investors,
there's one particular form
of government funding
that they say would make
a huge difference,
and it's called blended
or catalytic finance.
You see, the private sector,
banks and investors,
they have a lot of capital,
but not necessarily
always the right risk appetite.
On the other hand,
governments are willing
to take some risks,
especially for things
like the climate or shelter equity,
but they don't have as much capital.
So what blended finance involves
is governments deploying their finance
in instruments like guarantees,
or more concessional forms of lending,
and this allows
that private-sector finance
to flow when the governments
take on more of that risk.
And this kind of blended
or catalytic finance
has proven to be tremendously effective
in areas like affordable housing,
where a little bit of government money
can go a long way.
OK, great, so that's how we can
get some money flowing,
but there is more that we need
from governments,
and I call them the three p's:
public policies, programs, permits.
And to bring this to life,
let me tell you a story
of a bank that I'm working with.
They have bold ambitions.
They want to bring all the financing
in line with net-zero targets by 2050,
including their financing for homes.
And as we worked
to bring this ambition to life,
we ran into three key challenges.
In a lot of the markets
where they operate,
the right public policies
just weren't in place.
Minimum energy-efficiency standards
just didn't exist.
Moreover, the programs
to incentivize homeowners
to put solar panels on their roof
or retrofit their homes,
the kind of thing that the bank
was willing to finance,
they just weren't available
at sufficient scale.
And finally, when the bank was looking
for big-ticket things to finance,
like entirely new housing developments
that were affordable and low-emissions,
they found that projects
were held up in permitting.
And so their good intentions
remained stalled,
and so did the money.
But that's where people
like you and I can come in,
we the voters and constituents,
because we can demand
that governments do this.
We can demand that they
put in place that financing,
those programs, those permits.
And look, I get it.
Right now, it's a little bit
of a complicated time for many countries,
at the national level,
around climate-change policy.
But the exciting thing about housing
is a lot of the changes
that we need are superlocal ...
where small numbers of voters
can actually make a huge difference.
So let's do this.
Let's put climate and, importantly,
actions that drive climate finance,
at the top of the agenda
for every local government.
Let's write to our local officials
and say "Look, the banks and investors,
they're ready to put money to work.
And if we can just put in place
the right policies, programs, permits,
that money can come to our community."
Let's back the candidates
that back climate action
and, importantly, let's show up to vote.
OK, that's the first move --
we can mobilize governments.
But if we want to mobilize big money,
we also have to look
at the big balance sheets.
So here's the second move.
If you have an insurance policy
or a pension, this one's for you.
You see, pension plans,
insurance companies,
they're managing huge balance sheets.
They're often referred to
as institutional investors.
And these institutional investors,
they're managing your money
for the long run.
And the good news is that in recent years,
they have increasingly begun to appreciate
that the long-term risks associated
with climate change
present a material risk to their ability
to manage your money.
And so they've started taking action
to manage those climate risks.
Well, thanks to the pandemic
and the recent focus on racial equity,
they're now appreciating
that social inequities
also create these long-term
financial risks,
and they're ready
to step up and take action.
Here's some good news --
in 2020, investors financed over 140
billion dollars' worth of social bonds.
That's up from 17 billion
just the year before.
What are social bonds?
They’re bonds [where] proceeds can be used
towards addressing social inequities,
including things like affordable housing.
So when I talk to these investors
and ask them, "OK, you're doing
billions, that's great,
but what would it take
to get to trillions?"
they say it all comes down
to having a mandate,
a mandate to better integrate
these environmental
or social considerations
into how they manage your money,
the mandate to actually put
the money to work.
So how can we give them that mandate?
Well, there's two ways.
One is insurance companies
and pension plans
are increasingly giving you options
to move your money from a general pool
into a more dedicated one
that manages money
with greater environmental
and social considerations in mind.
And if you don't have
that option, demand it.
Large pension plans, insurance companies,
they have teams whose job it is
to listen to your concerns.
I know, because that was one
of my first jobs out of college,
to just answer phones
for a large pension plan in Canada.
And the more we speak up
and influence these large investors
who are managing our money
and make clear
how we want them to consider
environmental and social causes,
the more of a mandate they will have
to put those trillions to work.
OK, so first move is governments,
second is the institutional investors.
The third move is ourselves.
We need to create the demand
for these greener solutions.
Let me give you a few examples.
You know, most banks,
they'll offer a discount for your mortgage
if it meets minimum
energy-efficiency standards.
But guess what?
Few people take them up on that offer.
Similarly, I worked for a large
real-estate investment company.
They were willing to do the right thing,
to retrofit their buildings
and build entirely new ones
with new materials that would make it
a low-carbon building altogether.
But you know what they told me?
Aside from a few markets in Europe,
they just weren't seeing the demand.
So I think we can take some inspiration
from the other aspects of our lives,
like the food we eat
or the vehicles we drive,
where we have shown banks and investors
that it's worth financing
alternatives to meat,
or electric vehicles.
Let's bring that shift now
into the homes in which we live,
and let's show them that it's worth
financing more energy-efficient,
lower-carbon homes.
So when you're out to buy
or rent your next home,
ask about energy efficiency,
and even better,
ask about the overall carbon footprint.
So there are three things we can do.
We can activate governments.
We can mobilize these large,
institutional investors.
We can create the demand ourselves.
You know, as anyone in finance
would hate to admit it,
money doesn't make the world go around.
This big, beautiful blue and green
planet that we live on,
it's been spinning on its axis
for long before we were here
and will continue to do so
for long after we've gone.
What money can do is influence
just how long we'll be here
to enjoy the ride.
Thank you very much.
(Cheers and applause)